i wondered how you felt of nearly 20
years on
about the state of afghanistan today
very
unhappy and sad
for what we are witnessing in our
country right now
though we still have great achievements
of the past 20 years
the rise in education
millions of our girls going to school
and boys
and the place of women in the society
and afghan flag flying all over the
world
and much more
but seeing the continuation of conflict
the rise of extremism and terrorism
the arrival of daesh the emergence of
daesh
and the continuing fraternity side it is
in afghanistan
that makes me very very unhappy
has it been worth it i mean 20 nearly 20
years on trillions of dollars
thousands of lives in terms in terms of
the wishes of the afghan people for
an independent a sovereign
a country that which wished
to regain its own authority
and progress in life some has been
achieved no doubt
but in terms of the
main us and allies
objective in which the afghan all
people also shared joined hands
and into extremism stability in
afghanistan
peace in our country no it has been
disastrous for us
and who do you blame i
very very clearly
the approach
the policy the implementation of that
policy by the united states military
and some of their allies the american
forces
and their militias at times with them
come and barge into our homes
do things that are horrible
bomb our villages in the name of
fighting the taliban
yes we as the afghan people are on
society we have our issues we have our
difficulties
a lot of them like every other society
but the conflict that you see in
afghanistan is clearly the result
of imagination is this
for a global objective is this for a
regional rivalry of the united states
whatever the reason is we are the victim
of this ongoing sad saga in afghanistan
the entire international community
backed the prisons of the united states
in nato in afghanistan
in the name of the fight against
terrorism
but it was during their presence here
under their watch that
isis emerged in afghanistan how do they
explain that
how come how do you explain it what do
you put it down i have no explanation
other than to say that they did not want
to stop them
it emerged during
the u.s prisons in afghanistan in the
name of fight
against extremism and terrorism
so they have failed if
daesh emerged in afghanistan of its own
means
of its own ideology and for whatever
reason
during the presence of the united states
and
the western allies in nato afghanistan
then this mission has failed
so they better end this failed mission
do you have any regrets
about the decisions you made when you
were in power
some of the decisions of course i regret
some of the appointments
some of the other things but on the
question
of relations with the us and my
uh you know
policy towards them and my approach when
they begin to
view rough against afghan people no that
i'm very happy about
some of your critics might say that this
is a sort of
an abrogation of your own responsibility
i mean you were
the elected president but i i did what i
i did fulfill my responsibility by
telling the afghan people that that's
wrong by stopping the united states
of what they were doing i did that
and they they saw that as my opposition
to them no
it was my way of correcting them do you
think it's a good idea to
arm all the different militia groups who
are rising up to
to say where is it it is an army
we rebuilt the afghan state
we raised an army where is the police
force
we must keep the institutions of the
afghan state intact
so do you think it's a good idea to arm
the different militia groups no we
should be
we should we should be supporting our
own institutions
and we should not be fighting the
taliban should not be fighting
the taliban fighting against their own
people is
clearly for someone else's interest
this is a foreign conflict this is a
conflict for the interest of foreign
powers
not for afghanistan can you see taliban
being part of
the government they are they are afghans
they can be part of it
they must be part of it they must come
and live with all other afghans
and prove themselves through the will of
the afghan people
not through the guns that they have the
foreign guns that they have the guns
that they have or foreign guns
they must not prove themselves through
holding
foreign guns and firing those guns at
the afghan people
finally can you ever see yourself
stepping up to power again
no man i've i've done my time i've done
my time
i i i i i'm the architect of this
constitution
i created a democratic constitution for
afghanistan
i conducted elections and when my terms
ended i handed over to a successor
government through a democratic
procedure
i will not join that legacy i would
rather
keep that legacy alive and elections
being conducted in afghanistan
for as long as we here are and farzan
because that's the best system so no
i'm a citizen and where i will remain a
citizen but work for peace in our
country